I told you a moment ago that Santa Jared
the Home Secretary who cut short his
Christmas holidays has announced that
there will be two border force vessels
redeployed from their current duties to
help patrol in the English Channel he
spoke on camera a few moments ago
well yes earlier today I held meetings
with senior officials from the Home
Office from the National Crime Agency
and the border force to see what more we
can do both here at home but also with
our French friends in protecting our
borders
this incident around the channel it
remains of very serious concern to me
and that's why I declared it as a major
incident a few days ago it's at both
about protecting human life but also
about protecting our borders when it
comes to human life clearly I want to
make sure that we are doing all that we
can to protect people and we must
remember that this is one of the most
treacherous stretches of water that
there is 21 miles and with people taking
grave risk really Premier lives into
their own hands by taking this journey
and I want to make sure that we are
doing that all that we can and that's
one of the reasons I've made a decision
today to redeploy two of the border
forces largest vessels which are known
as cutters from abroad back to the UK
back to back to southeast England and
they will be joining a cutter that's
already there and two other coastal
patrol vessels that are there and this
will help both with the human side of
this situation but also to better
protect our borders but when it comes to
the borders there's also a lot more we
need to do I wish there was one single
answer but it does require action many
fronts and there's three other things
that I've decided to do both today and
in the in the run-up to this and much of
this works actually started weeks ago
but who tried to step it up further one
is on law enforcement both at home with
the National Crime Agency and the other
agencies that they work with but better
cooperation with our French partners we
already opened up for example a lot just
last month a new Coordination Center in
Calais which is a 24/7 man centre with
both British and French officials to
help to end this kind of a illegal
from France to Britain we've also
decided to do much more work on
disruptions because whilst we know about
the attempts that are successful in in
the sense that they actually these are
people that are making it to the UK
there are also many that are not
successful because the French have been
successful in I think about 40% of cases
so far this year in actually disrupting
them and stopping them leaving the
French coast and the French and the
British working together we want to get
the rate of disruption up so we're
looking at ways to do that both directly
but also in more covert ways and then
lastly I want to send a very strong
signal to people who do think about
making this journey is that we will do
everything we can to make sure it is not
a success in the sense that I don't want
people to think that if they leave a
safe country like France that they can
get to Britain and then just get to stay
and that's why I'm working out ways with
the French to increase the number of
returns that we can make to also send a
very strong message that we will do all
that we can not just to protect human
life because of course that's the right
and responsible thing to do at all times
but also to protect our borders which
could encourage more people to make that
perilous trip so how will you prevent
that from happening and what happens to
those migrants that you do pick up in
the channel will they be returned to
France
well there is also a balance to be
struck in terms of patrolling our waters
we on the one hand those vessels from
border force they're a very important
job to do in terms of protecting our
borders and in trying to whether it's in
this case torrid migrants but they also
do a big job for example in terms of
customs and customs fraud and protecting
our borders in that way - on the other
hand there there is a human side to it
in that if you if do come across anyone
in distress a difficult situation of
course our officers will act and do the
right thing so there's a balance to be
struck and what I've decided today if I
look at the assets a cross-border force
and what we have but given the current
situation the right thing to do is to
redeploy some of those assets and make
sure that
we are both protecting human life but at
the same time protecting our borders how
many migrants have made the journey in
the last month and how do you know
they're illegal migrants as you tweeted
earlier this week well we we know first
of all in this this year we've seen an
increase in the number of crossings but
especially in the last three months so
of all the crossings that we know about
this year approximately almost about 80%
of them have happened in the last three
months
in the month of December for example we
know of around 200 and I think 230
migrants that have attempted to make the
crossing but of those just under half
have actually been disrupted by the
French and never actually made it in
terms of leaving the French coast so
those are the numbers that we are aware
of at the moment and I do understand
some people say well you know that these
aren't huge numbers but let's also
remember that your our job here is to
make sure this doesn't turn into some
new route for ever increased illegal
migration so I want to try and stop it
now as much as I possibly can but also
this is a very very treacherous journey
it's a lot more dangerous than other
routes that we've known of in the past
and no one wants to see a fatality
if these cutters do pick up migrants in
the channel will they be returned to
France or will they be welcomed into the
UK well we're working with the French on
a more cooperation in terms of returns
but if they are picked up in English
waters just as they are now either by
border force or volunteers from the RNLI
or others that they will be at that
point they will be brought back into
British waters and that is what we would
do initially but we're gonna be
assessing any claim that they may or may
not make for asylum but that's why I
think the law enforcement work and the
returns policy is very important to both
crack down on these gangs and these
gangs of people traffickers that are
taking advantage of so many people by
selling them a completely false
prospectus and we don't want that we
want to crack down there's been some
excellent work that's been done on law
enforcement in recent weeks especially
the French recently made their three
significant arrests and those suspects
are being Tara gated now
but there's a is I think there's a lot
more to come on law enforcement
cooperation